Learning new details about
yet another senior Russian official
who's died as of now of unknown causes.
Russia's deputy minister of science
and higher education died after falling
sick on a plane on Saturday,
according to a Russian state
run broadcaster.
His family says his death
may have been from a heart condition,
but a forensic examination
is set for Wednesday.
His death obviously comes amid
a string of other deaths
among top Russian
officials and executives,
some of them questionable.
CNN's Matthew Chance
joins me now with details.
So what more do we know about this
senior Russian official
Well, you can see from the picture
that he is relatively young,
certainly not the age
you'd expect somebody to suffer
heart disease and die.
But of course, that doesn't
that doesn't really act.
He was a deputy minister
for education and science
and he was killed
or he died, rather, on a government trip
coming back from Cuba.
He died on the airplane.
He was on an official delegation in Cuba.
He was coming back.
He died on the airplane.
You mentioned that his his family.
They are waiting for the outcome
of the forensic report,
which the Russian authorities
say is underway.
But there's been this sort of telegram
journalist to who who says he knows
this this minister
who said that he spoke to him
before he left the country
and he said
he wasn't feeling great
about the situation.
In Russia
and they expressed reservations
about the direction
the country was going.
He said he was on antidepressants
and sort of feared for his own safety.
It's not evidence in itself, of course,
that there was any sort of untoward
malign activity towards this person.
But, you know,
it's as you said,
Russia has a very checkered past
when it comes to eliminating people
who don't necessarily follow the
the official line.
Yeah,
there was also this incursion
into Russia by Russians
fighting with Ukrainian armed forces.
What more do we know about it?
Yeah, I mean, that's that's
pretty pretty stunning.
This is a group of individuals
that say
that they're Russian nationals,
that they're they're based in Ukraine,
and they're using that as a base
with which to
from which to launch attacks
against Russia. Will today.
They carried out an extraordinary armored
advance into Russian territory
and actually seized land inside Russia
from the Russian state.
Take a look
threatening ominous here
tonight.
Russian forces insist
they're taking back control
from a group of what they call saboteurs
infiltrating this leafy border.
These
images purporting
to show a Russian soldier
detaining three of them
was broadcast on state media
and they get to meet
the anti-Kremlin Russians
now taking the fight back home.
Now, more than double that
This is how we work, he says.
Amid a bold armored raid
across the Ukrainian border
into Russia itself,
CNN cannot independently verify
any of the images,
but this entire column of vehicles
was spotted crossing the frontier.
Ukrainian forces
insist it's not them,
but exiled Russian groups
fighting against the Kremlin
with a key, usually significant way.
We are Russians just like you.
We want our children
to grow up in peace and be free
so they can travel, study and be happy.
But this is not possible
in Putin's Russia. Establish
this particular area.
And the
raid caught Russian
border guards unawares.
Well, this one tried to be a hero,
the narrator says.
Amid the scattered passports
and a portrait of Vladimir Putin
overlooking the carnage below
I should have thought no.
The border is now unlocked,
says one of the fighters.
The other Putin ramp up.
Putin will soon turn to honey,
says the other.
In other words, die nearby,
pointing at them
by the fellow
on Kremlin controlled television.
The presenters stood like statues
as the day's events replayed
stored
on videos from stunned locals.
Witnessing the fight
the Kremlin called the attack
a diversion.
But already this sharp criticism
from Russian hard liners
that this was allowed to occur
This Russian region
right next to
Ukraine,
is no stranger to cross-border attacks,
but armed incursions like this are rare
And the mood here,
according to local Russian officials,
has shifted
with empty busses coming in
to evacuate residents while those you can
are leaving by themselves
Well, Anderson, Russia has now declared
a counter
terrorism operation in the region, saying
it has killed or captured
dozens of those people
that came across the border from Ukraine
to carry out this raid.
But it is still unclear tonight
whether Russian government forces
have actually recaptured the territory.
That was sort of taken and seized
in this extraordinary raid.
Yeah, it's incredible.
Matthew Chance, appreciate it.